what is going on guys this is
statistically challenged and today I've
got another video for all you guys as
you can see we are on the Deadman mode
service as a level 3 we don't have
anything on us or interbank a few weeks
back I made a video similar to this one
where I took one GP to varrock and I
only use shops to see how much money I
could make from it this video is gonna
be the similar idea but on Deadman mode
and today I'm going to be using anything
I can find on the ground in varrock
anything I can transform like I can use
a bowl on a fountain to make a bowl of
water or any of the shops and then I'm
just gonna be selling it to the GE at
the end of the hour I'm pretty pumped to
see how much we can make and I hope you
guys enjoyed this video ok guys so I
just picked up some stuff from a guide
killing cards and we got three rounds
arrows some ashes and some iron daggers
I'm actually over here right now with
these bushes and I'm just gonna collect
some berries and get back to you guys
[Music]
see every just got something relatively
close to evil inventory the reason I
started here is because it's something I
can do with no GP I'm just picking
berries and yeah let's hope to not get
killed by the Wizards here hopefully if
you sell all right the bronze arrows
sold for two GP each we're now gonna
dump the iron dagger that's
unfortunately not selling I'm not
surprised
the ashes should go for a decent amount
I'm guessing okay five GP that's not bad
we're gonna dump the berries in at 1 GP
and see what happens here so the red
berries aren't selling the cadaver
berries let's see if they go for
anything and they don't as well that's
unfortunate I'm walking to the general
store because now I have some money and
I just found a bowl in the middle of the
fountain here so I'm just gonna pick it
up and pretty much use this on the
fountain here to get a bowl of water
yeah the reason I pick the berries up
was because I thought people needed them
for dyes so I thought they'd be in
somewhat of a demand but I guess I was
wrong
so yeah we're just gonna dump all this
stuff so much the iron dagger went for
14 coins the red berry went for 1 okay
the devil berries went for nothing red
berries gave me 3 GP somehow and I sold
eight okay okay so we're just gonna go
back and we're gonna buy some stuff that
we're gonna buy it with bowls the
buckets and we're also gonna get the not
the pots but the jugs these are all
things I can fill with water so you know
I can transform these items into being
something worth worn and every go we're
just waiting for the stock to come back
up on the jug we've now used up all our
money and we're just using all of these
items on the mountain to get all of them
filled with water now we're just gonna
go back to the GE and just pray that
this stuff actually sells for something
while I was walking to the GE people
were killing the guards here at the
barrel Palace and I just looted
everything that was on the ground you
know it's free [__] and I said you can
take stuff off the ground if you see it
as some one of the rules for the
challenge I also came up here and I
looted these guys ashes who's making the
fire by the farming patch because at the
end of the day boys this is a challenge
and we're trying to go for as much as we
can
[Music]
all right so the bowls of water in the
buckets water and the cabbage seats
didn't actually sell on the GD but we
got 370 P from that someone was killing
guards here and there was just coins
bones cabbage seeds leftovers so you
know I thought of might as well looted
while I'm on my way back to the general
store where I'm gonna dump these items I
came in at the general store now and
we're gonna dump all this stuff we're
gonna get a few coins here and there I'm
gonna plan to leave the bones though and
then the iron knife for the GE we're
gonna make our way over to the archery
shop here
this worked really well in the last V
Rock challenge video so I'm just gonna
buy all of these bronze arrows out with
the GP I have now because these did have
a big margin on the live game back to
the GE I'm just stopping again to pick
up the bones the seeds and coins left by
the people killing the guards it's just
a few way to pick up some extra cash on
the way back alright so a bronzer herb
is selling for seven GP we just sold all
all of them for six GP each which wasn't
too bad the iron knife is probably gonna
go six GP not bad the bones aren't
selling right now I'm gonna put the
sweet corn seeds in for one coin and see
what they go for holy [__] okay this
weak currencies went for 195 each that's
huge we're gonna dump the bones and we
should get that was fun now we're at 2.2
K guys it's been 15 minutes we're back
at the archery shop and with this money
we're just gonna buy out the bronze
arrows I also want to test out the steel
myth and Adam and arrows to see if we
could find a margin on the grand
exchange so we're just gonna do that
real quick we're plugging a buyout all
the bronze arrows as well just because
those do make the most money we're gonna
have to roll top a few times because
obviously the stock is gonna be out and
there's only like eight worlds sorry up
so what you guys watching now is just
sped up footage of me buying the bronze
arrows and world hopping thus far bronze
arrows are probably gonna be the main
source of profit here I mean you can buy
them for one to two coins when it's full
suck and then you can sell them for up
to seven GP I think later in the video
actually silver for eight or nine GP but
yet these have a very good margins so if
you're looking for some quick cash this
is a really good method of actually
making money
[Music]
alright guys we just finished buying
everything we could with our cash we're
gonna buy up to bronze bolts just so we
can use all the GP an inventory we are
back at the grand exchange our ash sold
for 1 GP you know it's one GPU guys I'll
[__] take it the atom and arrow is
not selling we bought them for 80 each
are enough to dump them yet same with
the mithril arrows these are not good
you can't actually profit off these
buying them from the in the archer shop
so we're just gonna dump these let's see
if the steel arrows have anything going
for us alright so the steel arrows
actually sold for 19h which is really
good because we only bought them for 12
and for the bronze arrows again we're
gonna put them in 4 or 5 GP ok so a lot
of them sold their breed and dumped the
bronze bolts at least forget our 2 GP
back ok that's good I'm gonna try buying
a bronze 0 for 8 GP so it's not actually
buying so that means it could sell it
for HUP alright so I've settled on 7 GP
for the bronze arrows these will all
eventually sell so what I'm gonna do
while waiting is just go back and
actually buy other stuff with the money
I have in my inventory just so it's more
efficient so I can just do this stuff
while waiting ok the one shop we can't
forget about it's this shop right here
the Sally is if that's how you say a
hiring buck care but this shop has
aprons and silk I think you need all of
these for a quest apron silk um trip at
the pink skirt but I know the brown
apron and Dee normal apron and these
silk like it might actually go over
something we're gonna pick up some other
bodies in case some Rangers you're
trying to buy some overpriced all other
bodies and yeah that's it from this shop
actually
there better be like 12 people trying to
buy a beer for 1k all I'm saying
okay the last shop I'm gonna hit up is
the rune shop I bought a death ruin
chaos room air in mind these are all
commonly used again guys all you see
some best base footage of Ben selling
all the stuff I'll tell you how it went
after the footage ends okay so
everything we just bought was pretty
much junk we lost some money on all the
runes and yeah we just wasted a lot of
time back at the general store she's
dumping everything that didn't sell keep
in mind I know it's Deadman mode and the
GE isn't as fast as the live game but
I'm kind of lazy so I'm just gonna dump
it all right guys back where the money's
at we are at the archer shop again let's
get the marrows so that took like five
minutes but look how many [__] arrows
we have boys all of these have margins
on the GE and I hope they'll sell right
away all right so the bronze arrows
aren't at seven they're not selling
we're gonna put the iron arrows in
before 7gp yep they all sold now as for
the steel arrows I have to dump them at
eleven they weren't actually going for
19 like those promised as you can see 10
bronze arrows just sold for 7gp
so I think we're just gonna leave these
in here for now we put them up to
actually 8gb and they're actually
selling because no one is pretty much
selling bronze arrows I'm the only one
selling bronze arrows okay guys so we
just made the riskiest investment ever
we bought one battle staff from zaps
shop it causes 7k okay back at the
general store we're gonna pick the
chisel of tinderbox pick up the two
bowls and fill them with water because
you know that's how you make the money
now but really I have an idea with these
two bowls I think I'm gonna use them on
a fire later so yeah after buying the
arrows again with the remaining cash we
were just going to sell everything back
the bowls of hot water if they don't
sell for now okay we're gonna use these
later and we're gonna make them bowls of
hot water on a fire we're gonna put the
battle staff in for around 8 K we're
actually gonna leave it at the seven
point nine see if it sells bronze eros
are selling nicely tinderbox okay guys
this chisel just sold for 250 GP this is
what I mean so many of you probably
denotes but if you
like bowl of water on a fire you can get
a bowl of hot water I think this is
required for a few quests but you know I
have no [__] idea we're just gonna
chuck them into the GE and see if they
sell because who the hell is like making
these right now a Deadman mode and
they're not actually selling which is
big at upset but I don't think anyone
will so we're gonna put them in for 500
each and see if we get lucky the bronze
arrows are still not all buying so I'm
gonna probably dump them right now
and they sold for 5 GP each not too bad
the battle staff is a risky call we're
gonna put it in for 7.3 K alright guys
so now for the battle staff in 10000 GP
remember we did start from absolutely
nothing we're in 46 minutes I think
we're heading back to the archery shop
so yeah just before the archer shop we
stopped by the general store and hit two
chisels I'm also gonna pick up a fire
staff on the way to the GE to see if
it's worth it ok the staff of fire was
1.5 K I don't see why this would go for
hire this was a stupid buy I'm probably
enough to dump it so yeah we'll see how
much money we lose okay we lost like 500
GP they're not bad
again these bowls of hot water aren't
selling another chisel did sell for 250
though which is a pretty big the blue
skirts also not selling these items are
just pretty garbage again at the general
store we're gonna pick up a few hundred
boxes few chisels and get some hammers
so you can get some good prices for
those just gonna buy some arrows then
rush you're gonna go down to the roof
shop alright so guys we're leading up to
the 1 hour mark and we just bought a
bunch of water runes a lot of people
need these fierce snares so I thought
they'd be you know in high demand
alright guys the hour is now over and
we're going to just dump everything on
the GE to see if we can just get a cash
pile going I think for one hour on the
Deadman mode server we actually made
quite a fair amount anyways I'm just
gonna put up the music of me selling all
this stuff and I'll get back to you guys
when I have the final amount and we'll
see how much we made
[Music]
alright guys so after using nothing but
looting stuff off the ground and buying
stuff from shops we've managed to make
20k 973 GP keep in mind this is really
good for Deadman mode especially day 2
you can swap this for a fair amount of
oh seven GP if you'd like of course
these these swapping clients at your own
risk you never know who's scamming or
not until next time guys have a good day
and if you liked this video and you want
to see more subscribe and check out my
other content I'm not gonna ask you to
leave a like I just want you to leave an
honest rating on how you thought the
video was done and until next time I
think I already said this have a good
day guys